good afternoon my name is Bill rickard
along with Jack Hyland we are co-chairs
of the board of trustees of Teachers
College and I have the distinct pleasure
of opening today's ceremony on behalf of
the entire community at Teachers College
I welcome you to the 2011 doctor'll
hooding ceremony it's now my honor to
introduce the president of Teachers
College susan h Furman
good afternoon welcome to our doctoral
hooding ceremony at Teachers College
today a feeling of joy which poet
friedrich schiller described as that
bright spark of divinity permeates this
magnificent Cathedral joy fills the
hearts of those unsung heroes who bore
so many sacrifices to make it to this
day I'm speaking of the parents partners
and children of our graduates doctoral
candidates would you rise and give a
round of applause to your families
I particularly loved the ceremony
because there are so many young children
in the audience reminding me of when I
got my doctorate degree from Teachers
College in 1977 and had my three little
ones with me there as well joy also
touches the hearts of tc's faculty and
staff who have mentored nudged and
nourished or doctoral students on their
critical paths all the way to defending
their dissertations again let's salute
the faculty and staff
and joy surely dwells in the hoods and
hearts of our graduates who have tested
their ideas and completed their
apprenticeships in TCS Laboratory of
knowledge and I am overjoyed to welcome
our graduates as colleagues into tc's
fellowship of scholars and professionals
throughout the world congratulations
well done
now don't get too comfortable we're
hardly done with you starting tomorrow
or perhaps later this afternoon we are
counting on you to join us in the task
of shaping the learning century as we
lead the way in education scholarship
policy and practice this will be our
moment education shines as the coin of
the realm and world affairs and for good
reason education drives innovation and
fuels productivity it is the lifeblood
of diversity and democracy it is the
cornerstone of Public Health and civic
health and yet we are fighting uphill
battles together on multiple fronts to
protect this precious currency we are
fighting to reverse a nationwide high
school dropout epidemic that condemns
more than a million American teenagers a
year to lives of poverty despair and
drift we are fighting to reduce ever
widening gaps and educational
opportunity and achievement within our
country even as we simultaneously
struggle to catch up to other nations in
math and science we must fight to stem a
rising tide of ridicule suspicion and
anger aimed at professional educators
and scholars the overwhelming majority
of whom are enormously dedicated to
their craft and we must also fight
against the reverence for the bottom
line that sees education strictly as a
business a business where metrics are
everything and the only measures we now
have our scores on tests that we all
find wanting let us be clear you and I
are not in the education business we are
however very much responsible for the
business of Education and learning we
are forever seeking answers to the
question that John Dewey as time and
time again throughout his legendary
tenure at Teachers College what is the
business of Education is it to
indoctrinate and
students for jobs today or is it to
foster creativity independence and an
appetite for lifelong learning is it
simply to ensure that high school
seniors can locate countries like
Afghanistan and Pakistan on the map or
is it to empower them to understand the
complexity of cultural religious and
geopolitical forces that will exist and
persist in that region of the world is
it simply to ratify the popular
educational tastes and trends of the
times or is it to develop powerful and
enduring solutions rooted in scholarship
practice and evidence that will stand
the test of time each of you has already
advanced the business of education by
pursuing your own both scholarly paths
as this sampling of dissertation titles
attests effects of academic track school
gender location and sector on secondary
school mathematics achievement results
from six districts of Punjab Pakistan
the effects of computer gaming on
student motivation and basic
multiplication fluency an Asian approach
to operations with fractions can
achievement be enhanced by a mechanistic
heuristic practice makes personal a
study of the formative experience of
jazz pianist nurse manager emotional
intelligence staff nurse satisfaction
and staff nurse retention do personality
traits project compliance with type 2
diabetes regimens perceived difficulties
to engaging in a diabetes diet in an
urban minority population this is
elsewhere org colon users and machines
making literacy work on blogs the art of
the everyday a spiritual journey of
aesthetic experience within Western and
Japanese context who's the expert the
influence of accountability based reform
and teacher accountability on the
classroom practice of suburban middle
school teacher
the Tweed effect theorizing the rise of
online learning in the New York City
Public Schools developing expertise in
professional American Orchestra
conductors brokering culture and labor
and anthropological analysis of IT
offshore labor between Japan and India
an analysis of Bruce OHS Miller in a
community college calculus laboratory
mathematics curriculum changes in the
Republic of Serbia for grades 5 to 8
after the breakup of the socialist
Federal Republic of Yugoslavia an
investigation of ethical thinking in
role-playing video games a case study
making sense of accountability a
qualitative exploration of how eight new
york city high school principals
negotiate the complexity of today's
accountability landscape preparing
teachers and autism spectrum disorders
reflections on teacher quality and a
higher degree of justice considering
fairness and capability in higher
education access and then there is the
dissertation that probably speaks to
every graduate use of strategies for the
relief of symptoms of insomnia behind
every dissertation lied tens of
thousands of hours of hard work
sacrifice and frequent frustration all
leading to an important insight on
learning the true scholar Ralph Waldo
Emerson rights finds consolation in
exercising the highest functions of
human nature he raises himself from
private considerations and breathes and
lives on public and illustrious thoughts
he is the world's I he is the world's
heart Emerson could have been describing
victor lin victor lin and accomplished
jazz musician and instructor in columbia
university's highly regarded louis
armstrong jazz performance program and a
doctor'll graduate today Victor was
troubled that the jazz department at
lumbia maintained a stringent audition
policy that allowed only the more
talented musicians to qualify for
private lessons or placement and
performance ensembles everyone else was
turned away this struck me he said as a
lifelong educator as counterintuitive
the very thing that students needed in
order to become better musicians was the
very thing they couldn't qualify for
experience and teaching Victor resolved
to do something about it with the
support of our music and music education
department he designed and ran a
year-long experiment the teachers
college jazz workshop the workshop was a
godsend to students who couldn't get
into colombia's program it furnished
them with a rich educational jazz
environment that allowed them to blossom
as musicians and it helped thick to grow
into an educational innovator and leader
by eliminating the traditional
teacher-student hierarchy and focusing
instead on learning victor was able to
unleash the individual and collective
energies of the learning community the
payoff from the experiment three of the
students from the workshop were placed
into Columbia ensembles in the spring
semester while Victor was hired by
Columbia to teach jazz improvisation
best of all the Jazz Department changed
its audition policy today every
auditioning student is placed in an
ensemble
Victor's insights into teaching and
learning music speak to all educators
the reality of music education is that
99% of people who participated music
making will never be thought of as the
best in the world but that's not the
point of learning rather the point of
learning is forming relationships
building communities and learning how to
be a human being it is about struggling
to go beyond what you think you're
capable of Victor and all his fellow
graduates here today could not have
picked a better time for earning a
doctorate from teachers college just
like Victor we must see every challenge
all the problems in the hurdles we face
as opportunities they all mean that our
efforts will be that much more important
and significant and necessary long ago
Emerson told a room full of scholars
much like yourself this time like all
times is a very good one if we but know
what to do with it graduates this is
your time your moment for shaping the
learning century draw on the wealth of
life-changing experiences you enjoy here
build on the friendships you made here
and by all means make your time the very
best of times for us all thank
we have now reached the moment to
present the teacher's college medal for
distinguished service the highest honor
the College bestows we honor those
extraordinary women and men whose life's
work has advanced the cause of Education
while upholding tc's own mission to
foster excellence and equity in the
fields we serve the Distinguished
Service Medal has been given in past
years to Archbishop Desmond Tutu Coretta
Scott King senator George Mitchell Pete
Seeger Tom servo Lee Schulman Gail
Collins Spike Lee and many others this
year our medalists our eminent exemplars
former New York Times Colonist and
author Bob Herbert Baltimore City
Schools CEO dr. andres alonso and one of
our nation's leading scholars and
innovators in teacher education and a
former TC faculty member dr. Linda
darling-hammond mr. Herbert and dr.
Alonzo received their medals at
yesterday's Masters convocations now
here to present dr. darling-hammond with
her medal is our provost and Dean Thomas
James
it is my pleasure to welcome to the
podium and Lynn Goodwin associate dean
of teacher education and professor of
Education in the Department of
curriculum and teaching professor
Goodwin will present our medalist Linda
darling-hammond Thank You Provost James
and good afternoon everyone Linda
darling-hammond you have written that
questions of teaching practice are not
simple predictable or standardized and
that instructional decisions cannot be
formulated on high and handed down to
teachers you have lived this philosophy
as a social scientist developing hugely
influential educational approaches
rooted in your work in schools and
classrooms you are a former public
school teacher you found it a preschool
a daycare center and a charter school in
one of the nation's poorest communities
that now sends ninety percent of its
students to college at TC where your
work remains a touchstone you co-founded
the National Center for restructuring
education schools and teaching which has
conducted pioneering analyses of
successful schools and through the
school to redesign network at Stanford
you have developed implemented and
evaluated new school models across the
country with that matchless breadth of
experience you have led major
initiatives addressing the most profound
educational challenges of our times you
have chaired councils and committed that
set learning curricula and assessment
standards in New York State and
established standards for the licensing
of new teachers nationwide also under
your direction the National Commission
on teaching and America's future built a
national coalition of states that made
sweeping changes to teacher education
week ranked the commission's report
among the most influential research
studies affecting American education and
named you among the decades 10 most
influential people affecting us
educational policy
Linda darling-hammond in 2008 speaking
at Teachers College as candidate Barack
Obama's education advisor you sounded
the call to ensure that everyone gets
what is really a new civil right access
to a high quality education you have
championed policy that in your own words
not only enables schools to meet the
intellectual demands of the 21st century
but also enables our society to pay off
the educational debt to disadvantaged
students that has accrued over centuries
of unequal access to quality education
for that work we are proud to award you
the Teachers College medal of
distinguished service
thank you so much I could not be more
honored than to be awarded this
recognition from teachers college one of
the places of all those I know in the
world that holds the tightest grip on my
heart and best represents my values and
beliefs I feel like I'm home a place
that in the work of my many treasured
colleagues and former students from the
years I spent here continues to make me
enormously proud to be a continuing
member in the TC community thank you for
this recognition and more important
Thank You teachers college faculty
trustees students and graduates for who
you are and what you do my first real
glimpse of what teachers college is and
does occurred not here in New York City
and not in my tenure here but in a
school in Washington DC where I lived at
the time and where one of my children
had transferred into a first-grade
classroom to avoid the terribly truly
terrible teaching that was literally
making her sick in another school in her
new school Elena's teacher Miss Leslie
as she was called by the students had
created a wonderland of stimulating
opportunities for learning children
experimenting and investigating in the
classroom and the community designing
and conducting projects writing and
publishing their own little stories one
that my daughter wrote after the birth
of her little brother was entitled send
him back we still have that on the
bookshelf at home this teacher who was
in her very first year of teaching not
only had created a classroom that any
mother would want to send her child to
but she also had a skillful I and
knowledge base to figure out within
weeks that Elena was severely dyslexic
she taught her to read without her ever
being labeled or stigmatized and
instilled in her a lifelong love of
books and learning that has led to my
daughter being a literacy teacher
working with special needs
students today one day I asked miss
Leslie how she had learned to do this
miraculous work as a brand new teacher
and she told me that she had learned to
be this kind of teacher at Teachers
College Columbia University she listed
the courses she took in the curriculum
and teaching Department and in a special
education program that built her
knowledge base and described what she
had learned with intensive supervision
and a carefully designed clinical
placement it was then that I knew that a
profession of teaching was possible and
I learned much more about what is
possible in building a profession from
my colleagues here and in our partner
schools when I later came to teach at
Teachers College I became persuaded that
policymakers needed to understand how to
enable all educators to acquire the
knowledge and skills that could truly
allow all children to learn rather than
to try as so many have to manage
teaching from afar through mind-numbing
and ultimately futile prescriptions for
practice Teachers College has for more
than a century represented the heartbeat
of an education profession in the United
States and our deepest aspirations for a
democratic system of education when TC
was founded by grace dodge and 1887 it
was intended to provide a truly
professional education for the teachers
of the poor in New York City but just by
the research that was also planted in
the college at that time when most
teachers had little more than a high
school education TC teachers a group of
extraordinary men and women of all races
who came from all parts of the country
were earning master's degrees and
preparing for research based practice
then as now the creation of truly
professional educators was a subversive
business as scientific managers were
looking to make schools efficient in the
early 20th century to manage schools
with more tightly prescribed curriculum
more teacher proof texts more extensive
testing more rules and regulations they
consciously sought to hire
less well educated teachers who they
said would work for lower wages and
would go along with the factory model
regime of prescribed lessons and pasting
schedules without protest one speaker at
an any a meeting in 1914 observed there
were so many efficiency engineers
running hand cars through the school
houses in most large cities that grade
school teachers could hardly turn around
in their rooms without butting into two
or three of them during that decade
precisely a hundred years ago nationally
distributed tests of arithmetic
handwriting in English were put into use
their results were used to compare
students teachers and schools to report
to the public and even to award merit
pay a short-lived innovation due to the
many problems it caused does any of this
sound familiar in the view of these
brilliant managerial engineers
professionally trained teachers were
considered troublesome because they had
their own ideas about education and
frequently did not go along weekly with
the plan as one such teacher wrote in
the American teacher in 1912 and I would
wager that she was a teacher's college
graduate she said we have yielded to the
arrogance of big businessmen and have
accepted their criteria of efficiency at
their own valuation without question we
have consented to measure the results of
educational efforts in terms of price
and product but education since it deals
with human and humans and with
individuality is not a standardized amol
manufacturing progress it must measure
its efficiency in terms of increased
humanism increased power to do an
increased capacity to appreciate sounds
suspiciously like John Dewey and Maxine
Greene doesn't it while the scientific
managers foolishness was creating a
stranglehold on schools under the banner
of education reform TC teachers school
leaders and professors from John Dewey
to William Hurt kilpatrick to George
counts and more we're creating
progressive schools in which students in
aged in intellectual inquiry hands-on
projects activity based curriculum
guided by an understanding of child
development the new Sciences of learning
and the emerging practices of pedagogy
these schools practice democracy in
action and provided a counterpoint to
the factory model schools that do we
called mechanical dull uninteresting and
hardly educative in any meaningful sense
then as now TC graduates set the highest
standards planting the ideals of
democratic progressive education as
leaders in schools colleges and
governments all around the world and as
you probably know and as I have learned
there's almost nowhere you can go in the
world without finding amazing
educational work being done by the
graduates of Teachers College then as
now TC upheld the three core values that
represent a profession first a strong
ethical commitment to serve clients well
to make decisions based on what is best
for students not what is cheapest or
easiest or most expedient second a
mastery of a common body of knowledge
and skills along with the commitment to
always seek more and better knowledge to
meet students needs and oh how I love
that moment a TC at four o'clock when
the doors fly open and thousands of
people come in from New York City and
New Jersey and Connecticut with that
thirst for professional knowledge and
third a commitment to define and
transmit and enforce the highest
standards of practice a community that
pledges to work together to do the right
thing that commitment is more important
now than ever before our nation is on
the verge of forgetting its children the
United States now has a far higher
poverty rate for children than any other
industrialized country in the world
twenty-five percent nearly double the
rate of childhood poverty of thirty
years ago it has a more tattered safety
net more children who are homeless
without health care without food secure
d a more segregated and inequitable
system of public education with the
highest spending district spending ten
times more than the poorest districts a
larger and more costly system of
incarceration than any country in the
world including China's we have five
percent of the world's population and
twenty five percent of the world's
inmates and one that is now directly
cutting into the money we should be
spending on education a defense budget
that is larger than that of the next
twenty countries combined and greater
disparities in wealth than any other
leading country with the wealthiest one
percent of individuals controlling about
twenty-five percent of the resources in
this country and in New York City the
wealthiest one percent controlling
forty-six percent of the city's
resources our leaders do not talk about
these things they simply say of poor
children let them eat tests and while
there is lots of talk of international
test score comparisons there's too
little talk about what high-performing
countries like Finland and Singapore
actually do they fund schools equitably
they invest in high-quality preparation
mentoring and professional development
for teachers and leaders completely at
government expense and you earn a salary
while you're going to school and now
that's a heartbreaker when you're coming
out of Teachers College with debts and
commitments that you've made they
organize a curriculum around
problem-solving and critical thinking
skills and they test students rarely and
never with multiple choice tests indeed
the top performing nations use school
based assessments of learning
challenging projects and performances
like those that many of you have created
here in innovative new york public
schools meanwhile the profession of
teaching in our system of public
education are under siege from another
wave of scientific managers who have
forgotten that education is about
opening minds to inquiry and imagination
not stuffing
them like so many dead turkeys that
teaching is about enabling students to
make sense of their experience to use
knowledge for their own ends and to
learn to learn these new scientific
managers like those of a century ago
prefer teachers with little training who
will come and go quickly without costing
much money and without raising many
questions about an increasingly
prescriptive system of testing and
teaching that lines the pockets of
private entrepreneurs who provide
teacher proof materials which are deemed
necessary ironically in peak art in part
because there are so many underprepared
novices who leave before they learn to
teach curriculum mandates and pacing
guys that would choke a horse as one
teacher put it threatened to replace the
opportunities for teachable moments that
expert teachers know how to create with
their students the new scientific
managers like to rank and sort students
teachers in schools rewarding those at
the top and punishing those at the
bottom something that the highest
achieving countries not only don't do
but often forbid these managers would
create efficiencies by firing schools
firing teachers and closing schools
while issuing multi-million dollar
contracts for testing and data systems
to create more charts graphs and report
cards on which to rank and sort well
just about everything and they fail to
realize that you can't fire your way to
Finland that in fact and in places like
Finland a great profession of teaching
is built on the knowledge base and
supports that are provided finally the
new scientific managers have cleverly
constructed systems that solve the
problem of the poor by blaming the
teachers and schools that seek to serve
them calling the deepening levels of
severe poverty and excuse rewarding
schools that keep out and push out the
neediest students and threatening those
who work with new immigrant students
still learning English and the growing
number of those who are homeless and
without health care are their lower
scores in under-resourced schools with
high needs students fire the teachers
and the principal's close
the school's don't worry about the fact
that the next schools as researchers
have document men that are likely to do
no better the equivalent of deciding
that if the banks are failing we should
fire the tellers but public education
has a hidden weapon a Trojan horse the
members of the profession like
yourselves who have mastered a strong
body of professional knowledge who hold
a strong ethic of care who are
determined to transmit this knowledge
and this commitment to others throughout
the education system at Teachers College
are those who are leading the fight for
more equitable funding for public
schools and who won a major victory in
New York State there are those who are
leading the efforts to create more
thoughtful and creative curriculum and
instructional strategies and there are
those who are developing more effective
teacher and leadership education and
professional development among those of
you who are graduating are many who have
created and will create more exciting
and empowering schools for children more
useful and appropriate assessments of
learning more just and humane policies
to guide a system focused on learning
not selecting and sorting you will do
this in the strong professional
communities you have created here at TC
and in your work in the field you will
carry on the work of building a
profession that serves democratic
education one that provides for all
children what the best and wisest parent
wants for his or her child as John do we
put it many of you have arrived here
today a considerable personal sacrifice
but you are here because of the work to
which you have committed your lives and
because you know it is the right thing
to do and doing the right thing meeting
that professional commitment is not easy
weather is standing up for a child who
is mistreated or finding the energy to
go that extra mile to reach out to a
troubled parent or taking up a
challenging issue in the research or
taking on a difficult concern
in the public discourse doing the right
thing is often hard and as King said on
some positions cowardice asks the
question is it safe expediency asks the
question is it politic and vanity comes
along and asks the question is it
popular but conscience ask the question
is it right and there comes a time when
one must take positions that are neither
safe nor politic nor popular but he must
do it because conscience tells him it is
right take heart in knowing that the arc
of history as long as King says but it
bends towards justice take courage in
knowing that we're a community of hands
comes together to work toward justice a
freedom seed will grow and take pride in
knowing when the work is challenging and
setbacks come as they must when anything
important is happening that you are
building a better future for every child
and every family and every community
that you touch and remember as robert f
kennedy said it is from numberless
diverse acts of courage and belief that
human history is shaped each time a
person stands up for an ideal or acts to
improve the lot of others or strikes out
against injustice he sends forth a tiny
ripple of hope I thank you in advance
for each ripple of hope you will create
I thank you for spreading the spirit of
Teachers College you are the shapers of
this history so keep your hand on the
plow hold on thank you
you
Thank You Victor we'll see you again
it's now our pleasure to introduce the
department chairs who will in turn
announce each graduate as he or she is
hooded
for the Department of Arts and
Humanities Callie wait for Margaret
cacao welcome everyone what an
absolutely wonderful event it is my
great pleasure to present the doctor'll
graduates for the Department of Arts and
Humanities we know that this is the
first of many accomplishments as they
bring their formidable intellect there
are incredible energy and their critical
insights to their fields of
specialization congratulations to all
nyoka acai
Virginia and Alan
Barbara Wagner bashaw
your kool Madeline Becker
Rebecca burgoo
Harrigan McMahon Bowman
patricia and Carrie
Vivian Kim Cassie
hi Yoon Chang
Donna L Clovis
katherine theresa corcoran
jennifer lynn cuts forth
Kristen que de Janeiro
Diane dobri
Mariah Caroline Doran
Jeanette Catherine Faber
Robin Fryman L
jin sung han
Rebecca Joann Johnson
ah jung kim
Nina Carol Lasky
tiffany s lee
Victor jun wei lin Jane Beamer lindamood
Thomas Liam Lynch
karen lynn marston Dana Linn MacArthur
Stacy Redford McKenna
Danielle Marie McRoy
Stacy mehar Miller andrew Lee mount
Thomas Joseph Parenti
Kevin G Phillips Anastasia and pike
Christine widner puffer Lee and Riley
Donna Lynn rizzolo razia Iran Sadiq
Laura rice segreto
Jessica and slept winski Dennis Lamar
Stevens Winston Charles Thompson
cynthia Susan while jun yoshimatsu
she young you and once again
congratulations to our graduates in arts
and humanities
for the Department of bio behavioral
sciences Stephen Silverman thank you
Bill on behalf of the Faculty of the
Department of bio behavioral sciences
it's my pleasure to pizzette present are
strong but our small but strong number
of graduates our departments focuses on
the areas of movement science and
kinesiology on speech and language
pathology and a neuroscience and
education the students I'm about to
present to you all will go on in a line
of scholars who have graduated from our
programs over the years it's my pleasure
now to present and to congratulate the
graduates of the department of bio
behavioral sciences
you
Kevin John mercy ER Dawn Marie Nielsen
electra Petra Sharon rose Phillips
again congratulations to the doctor'll
graduates of the department of bio
behavioral sciences
George bonanno for the Department of
counseling counseling and clinical
psychology greetings Teachers College
Columbia University is a grand and
historic institution its name is
synonymous with great advances and
expansive ideas ideas that break
boundaries and open up new terrain it
should not be surprising then that the
name Teachers College cannot contain all
that goes on here this is especially
true when it comes to psychology
psychology has always played a rich and
varied role in the intellectual life of
this campus the class of clinical
psychologist and counseling
psychologists that will be hooded today
is no exception they've gone through a
rigorous training called a scientist
practitioner model as its name indicates
this model required that they learn to
think both as scientists and his
therapists that's a lot of work in a
sense you could say they've earned two
PhDs but the real challenge for these
degree about to be hooded degree holders
is integrating these two domains as
therapists our doctoral students have
had to learn to use their critical
skills to solve problems just as a
scientist would solve problems as
researchers they've had to find ways to
ponder the important questions of the
day practically and empathetically just
as a clinician would this challenge
integrating critical thinking with
empathy and practicality is exactly the
same challenge that same type of
challenge these men and women will face
when they leave us because of the
demanding nature of the scientist
practitioner approach however they will
be superbly well equipped to face those
challenges this is good for them it's
good for teachers college it's good for
psychology and best of all it's good for
human society and now it is my great
pleasure to initiate that final step and
to send our new class of psychologists
orly em athan Nancy moon cheat moon hee
cha sadia ramen chowdhury Alethea t road
desrosiers Laura Goren
simatic gupta Anita I Urco sorry Angela
bosun Kim
Annie I jun lin
Brenda xiomara may hear Rebecca Madeline
Reddington Cecilia albertha Rugare Mia
markley saved Jeanette and Sawyer Cohen
Karen Amanda shown
Errol shovel Vijay Etta Kumari sing
congratulations again to the newly
minted doctoral students of the
Department of counseling and clinical
psychology
for the for the Department of curriculum
and teaching james boorland good
afternoon our department has a word
curriculum in its name that has multiple
meanings that ancient fount of wisdom
wikipedia defines curriculum as the
subjects comprising a course of study in
a school or college now that's a
simplistic a nuanced definition that
does not begin to evoke the complexity
and multiplicity of meanings encompassed
by the word but it does get at the sense
of curriculum as the what that one
learns as when pursues one's education I
want to look at the word curriculum in
another larger context whereas in other
fields people have resumes in the
academy we have curriculum vitae where
academics we never use one word where
two will do curriculum vitae translates
as the course of one's life and what we
are celebrating here today is a landmark
event in the course of the lives of our
doctoral graduates we are exceedingly
proud to have been a significant part of
our graduates curriculum vitae we have
shared many days weeks months years of
struggle hope and ultimately triumph all
of which culminate on this day in this
place it's been our very good fortune
that our graduates curricula vti and
ours that is the courses of our lives
have flowed together for this period of
time in bidding them goodbye we hope
that the curricula their lives continue
to be as rich and rewarding and
meaningful as ours have been as a result
of having had the privilege of being
their teachers their mentors and their
friends the following are the 2011
doctoral graduates of the Department of
curriculum and teaching
ina l Austin
eliza s Engelberg
Lorraine Theresa falchi eric john
Hassler
dawn-marie Horton son ho moon
you
lisa beth pearl
mud and pillow
Jean Louise read
Ronald Kerwin salts
Jennifer Gallagher Scoggin
Valerie scenar
Kathleen Corcoran Tarrant
christina k white Julie Ann Patricia
worm again congratulations to our 2011
graduates
stephen Peverley for the department of
health and behavior studies good
afternoon welcome and thank you for
supporting our graduates the department
of health and behavior studies consists
of programs and health applied
psychology and special education our
mission is to Train scholars and
practitioners who will work to improve
the health learning and social
well-being of children and adults it is
my distinct pleasure today to present to
you the doctoral graduates of our
department they are an extraordinary
talented and dedicated group of men and
women who have worked extremely hard to
attain their goal and to appear from
before you today
muna al adduced
Arlene Michelle Alan
Joan Amanda wrote oil
Alison grassy Carson
Beth Jillian chase
grace Anna Clark hilliard Allison Mary
Corwin geoffrey alan de tes OU
Carly mohair EB
Lindsay bath farnham
Mary Elizabeth pasetta Elizabeth Grace
Finnegan Marianne homsi
crystal joy hidin
Rebecca Langley Wilson Jackson
Natasha f Joffrey
Maria Gabriela Kahless ji yong li
Susanna p Leon
our mine lu li Jian
Jacqueline Maffei
Amanda Mazen
brian christopher pack head
Rebecca and real lon
Nancy Oh st. Cyrus
Richard's IDs
Emily are shamash
pooja chugging vakharia
congratulations again to the graduates
of the department of health and behavior
studies
for the Department of Human Development
John black Department human development
has composed the programs of cognitive
studies and education developmental
psychology measurement evaluations of
statistics and sociology at education I
should have used the past test was this
marks the end of an era the sociology
program is moving to a new department in
the fall so this will be the final
graduates from our apartment in that
program leaving the department focused
on cognition and learning development
measurement statistics I'm happy to
present the 2011 graduates Department
human development
she sung cha
Oh
each on Chen
Jennifer Grossman
but she's at an extra name here so so
ask amanda jane home on Kroll ning son
Pierre Lou
isabel martinez
eun-suh Park
berto able Rodriguez
a yell at seagull
genet eisenbahn Sorkin
the shell van Noy
Michael Weinberg Therese Rosalie
wirkkala
congratulations to 2011 doctoral
graduates the department human
development
for the Department of International and
trans cultural studies Regina Cortina
for George bond next fall the Department
of International and trans cultural
studies will be composed of two
departments one of them is anthropology
and education the other is a combination
of comparative international education
and international education development
both programs have a long and
distinguished history both a teacher's
college and in higher education we also
currently have programs in economics of
Education and in bilingual bicultural
education these through programs will be
make migrating to other departments in
September the program in comparative
international education and
international education development are
for those seeking to become
professionals and leaders in
international development agencies and
non-governmental organizations all our
programs offer a world-class doctoral
degree as well as master's degrees for
those pursuing academic positions in
college and universities in the United
States and around the world our doctoral
programs provide on parallel preparation
in advance research and graduate level
teaching on behalf of all the faculty
colleagues in the Department of
International and trans cultural studies
I am pleased to present our graduates
Stephanie Lewis Bengston Steven sham
sack
GHI
radhika in a gar
mark there is your Shack
Pamela king
Patricia Meyer
is Stephanie missioner
I key code for that
Todd Evans 91 m
alexander ha sonic Leah Michelin Shapiro
and Campbell is Miley
Sarah cattery is made
you
Cecilia is peroni
Jennifer Aaron sweet Morgan
I'm
Lori Diane on the map
Elizabeth and Walsh giblin Mackey
cochino
slay you
you shall
congratulations again to all our
graduates in the Department of
International and
for the department of mathematics
science and technology Oh Roger Anderson
I'm very pleased to introduce the
candidates for three programs
mathematics science and communication
computing and technology and education
to the candidates please come forward
insar for saying good
Julie Anna Contino Natasha a cook nevis
matthew david the marina's
Frank OB agora knew you link you
call some hung
Valerie Camille Jones
mikio Renee Kent
jakey Lee
Dominic John mentor
young be Oh
Sam Howard rumley
Antonio's panagiotis serovar knows Karen
Lori schreier
arto no party chill
William Charles toes oh
Jenna Renee vom sickle
Nirvana logic
Nicholas hemming Wasserman
Adrienne's least wheeler
Yvonne Marsha Wilkinson our best wishes
to the candidates as they go forth to
serve humanity and I hope that they have
much happiness as we have had in serving
them all the best
Warner Burke for the department on
organization and leadership
if your organization needs to be
reorganized if your organization needs
to change and come into the 21st century
for heaven's sake if you need superb
leaders for your organization if you
need expertise about how to develop
superb leaders for your organization
these graduates are the people for you
you need to hire them just bear in mind
that their fees for their services
tomorrow will be doubled what they are
today the following are the graduates
from the Department of organization and
leadership John Andrew Andrew jack
colette boker
Diane rusher
alyce marie Cahill Teresa Ellen Cotter
Nancy and Goldman
Pamela Agnes who are
Chad david hogan
Christopher Patrick horrigan
latoya d an Ingram Mary J Catalan
sandy Michiko kuch
Zachary Lynn Alice Miriam man
makeba McCreery
Robert Bruce Morris
nayra musallam
helmet kinney nienhouse ER mid el
salvador piger again
dok1 Park
james parlor
Gladys in San Diago tu sada Gary Wayne
Smith
Andrea Robinson and Chen
Jennifer Burns Stillman
Carla and Theodora
easy
Dorothy Elise Weaver
jennifer ehle Yates congratulations to
the graduates from the Department of
organization leadership
I'm Robert Weintraub president of the
Teachers College Alumni Association it's
with great pleasure that I formally
welcome you our newest alumni into our
community you're joining a body of some
90,000 professionals from all our
departments and programs in all walks of
life at all stages of careers who have
made a significant mark in the world
they have done so because of their
intelligence sensitivity drive knowledge
experience and wisdom they have also
done so because of people like the ones
around you today family friends teachers
administrators trustees benefactors and
fellow alumni representing our alumni I
am here to tell you how valuable
participation in our association can be
we are colleagues and collaborators
supporters and challengers advisors and
networkers and what holds us all
together is our alma mater if your time
here was anything like mine you
experience moments of puzzlement angst
and weariness along with insight
inspiration and laughter and many of you
have developed what will be lifelong
friendships if your future time here is
anything like mine I can assure you that
your continued connection to TC will
continue to bring you in sight
inspiration left or in friendships right
now I know that your focus is and should
be on your work and careers you are
destined to do important things in
education development health care and
organizations but please know that you
have have a home and rich community
NTC which you can tap into physically
and virtually your fellow alumni along
with all the people here that make
Teachers College special wish you all
the best in your endeavors and we hope
we have the opportunity to join you
along the way
on behalf of the trustees of Teachers
College we would like to congratulate
each of you on your extraordinary
achievement and we'd like to celebrate
this with you now
so welcome doctor'll graduates of the
class of 2011 join us for light
refreshments in Russell courtyard at
Teachers College friends and families
we'd be grateful if you'd remain in your
seats until all of our students our
graduates have left thank you